-Our next guest is a talented
actress you know from her work
as Kamala Khan on the hit series
"Ms. Marvel."
All six episodes are available
now on Disney+.
Let's take a look.
-Oh. But no, I've spoken
too much already.
No, no, no, I'm not going to
talk about this at all.
-Kamala?
-Your mother will get
very upset.
-So this belonged to Aisha
and you really have no idea
what happened to her?
-Oh, beta, speak up a bit.
My old ears are not --
-Kamala.
-Please welcome to the show
Iman Vellani, everyone!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to the show.
-Thank you.
I am particularly very excited
about this one
because our producer Sana who
was on your Show in like 2016...
-Yes, here's Sana. She's one of
the producers of "Ms. Marvel."
And she was here.
And I guess you have watched
this interview.
-Oh, yes. It was the first thing
I watched after I read
the "Ms. Marvel" comics
for the first time.
And I was, like,
obsessed with her.
I was like, "How did she get
a job at Marvel Comics
and be brown and a woman
at the same time?"
-Seems like you'd be happier
about it.
You seem really mad about it.
-I was so jealous.
[ Laughter ]
Me being like 15 years old.
But yeah, I was obsessed
with her.
And now six years later I'm here
talking about "Ms. Marvel."
And she's here too somewhere.
-She is. She's backstage.
It was nice to see her again.
But again, I think this is
the part that's so sweet.
So, you obviously you cared
about this comic book
and now you're playing Marvel's
first Muslim superhero.
And she's a teenager
and you're a teenager.
And I can't even imagine --
also you're a comic book fan --
of what this whole process was
like, ending up with this part.
-My life is overwhelmingly good
right now.
[ Laughter ]
-That's good. Live it up.
There's no reason to be shy
about it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is it true, were you the kind of
person who you did
spend your allowance on
comic books?
-All $20.
-20 bucks?
-Yeah.
-Is that a good allowance
these days?
Because I have to start
figuring out --
-No, I had to make
an Excel spreadsheet
and, like, talk to my parents.
I'm like look, these are
my expenses
as a 15-year-old
high school kid.
I need comics.
I need McDonald's.
I need clothes, I guess? Yeah.
But it was just
McDonald's and comics.
-And you were a Marvel kid?
-Mm-hmm.
-Is that accurate?
-But it was mostly Iron Man.
So I obviously fell in love with
the MCU first and then
my high school was right across
from a comic book store,
and I was like,
"I need more Iron Man."
So I read every "Invincible
Iron Man" comic I could get.
And then I ran into Ironheart
'cause I thought she was
Iron Man.
That was wrong.
And Kamala was on the cover
of one of those comics
and that's when I fell in love
with her.
-I mean, I think, it is
important, you know, obviously
so special to have this kind of
representation in comics.
What was it like the first time
you saw "Ms. Marvel"?
-Ah. In person? In the mirror?
[ Laughter ]
No, it was crazy.
She felt so different than all
the other Muslim teenagers
I was used to seeing
in mainstream media.
She was using her culture as
something that guided her.
And it wasn't something
she neglected at all.
And on top of that
she was a huge fan.
And the show is -- The comics
were never about being Muslim
or being Pakistani.
It was about this
superhero-obsessed dork who just
happens to be
Muslim and Pakistani.
And that's how I felt
in real life.
And it was really comforting
reading those comics.
-Well, it certainly --
I think they ended up
on the right person
for the part.
So there's a really cool
animation style in this show
as well, outside of
the live action,
and it's so visually pleasant
and pleasing to watch.
Were you also someone who was
drawn to art growing up?
I feel weird say growing up
because I feel like
that hasn't finished yet.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm an adult?
No, but I was.
I was really into art.
It's funny.
During one of our quarantines,
I made a little stop-motion with
my Iron Man
and Kamala action figures.
And I sent it to Kevin Feige and
our producers with zero context.
It was like literally my action
figures dancing or something.
And then they really liked that.
And we ended up changing our
episode one opening animation
to be a stop motion instead of
like a regular animation.
-So Kevin Feige, who,
if anybody follows
the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
this is the man
who's pulling the strings.
He's sort of the brain
behind it all.
Did you feel nervous
when you first met him
or were you right away sending
him weird stop-motion animation?
[ Laughter ]
-So I didn't -- I stared at him
until he left the first time
I met him.
I like couldn't be a human
at all. I lost all function.
-And do you think he left
because you were staring at him?
-Possibly.
-Possibly, yeah.
-He's really awkward.
And if you're awkward, then it's
just a double whammy.
It's terrible,
but Sana was like,
"Okay, so he's coming on
Wednesday."
It was Monday.
And he comes and he's like,
"Hey, Iman, heard you're doing
a great job," or whatever.
And I was like --
[ Laughter ]
Stared at him until he left.
And then he came back Wednesday
and I had written this like
four-page letter.
The first page was like me
gushing over him.
The next three pages were
like 70 questions
about the MCU and his life.
And so I gave it to him.
And Sana was basically
our mediator throughout
this whole conversation.
She's like, "Iman, you have
something for Kevin.
Kevin, what do you want to say
to Iman?"
[ Laughter ]
And it was like really awkward.
And I gave him this letter,
and the next day he called me
and like answered
the first 40 over Zoom.
So yeah.
-Alright.
-I am more comfortable
with the man now.
[ Laughter ]
-That is very nice to hear.
It must be so --
I could only imagine.
You've been working for
two years on this project.
And now you can finally talk
about it with people.
You've known secrets.
You've known plot points that
you haven't been able to share.
Has it been rewarding to talk to
fans who have responded to it?
-Dude, I can breathe.
It's so nice.
I'm like -- I'm not present
on social media publicly
but I do have like a lot of
private accounts.
Especially on Reddit.
I'm just like arguing with
people about theories.
I'm like, "You don't even know
what's coming, man.
Like, you're so wrong."
It's so liberating.
[ Laughter ]
-So you also had to keep
a secret about auditioning
for this in the first place
from your friends.
Everyone -- You were planning on
going to college, right?
And just put a pause on that.
-Yeah.
I was like with my friends.
I was planning rooming together
at university.
Little did they know that was
not going to happen
'cause I got the part in front
of them
and they were like, "What?"
-What could you mean
in front of them?
-So it was the last day of
high school and we were out
doing stuff and I get this text
from Sarah Finn
and she's like, "Hey, can you
get on this call?"
And I was like, "No."
And then they were like,
"We sent you the link.
Get on right now."
And I was like, "Okay."
And I'm in my friend's driveway
and they're watching me
from the car and I'm trying to
not have a reaction
'cause Kevin Feige's
on my phone.
It was just --
My brain was spinning.
And then I get back in the car
and they were like,
"So what happened? Did you like
win the lottery or something?"
And I was like, "Basically."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-And then how did you celebrate?
-Burritos. We got burritos.
-Yeah. Burritos?
-Yeah.
-Well, I think that
there's no achievement
that that's not
the proper celebration for.
-I'd say so.
-What a delight to spend time
with you this evening.
Congratulations on everything.
-Thank you so much.
-I just met you
but I don't think
it could have happened to
a nicer person.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys, that's Iman Vellani.
All episodes of "Ms. Marvel" are
available now on Disney+.
We'll be right back.